ja ich danke sehr herzlich für die
einladung gerne gefolgt bin
man kann eigentlich sagen dass bei so
einer tat
wo es um klassische und offensichtlich
oberhalb der sichtbarkeit schwelle durch
aufhaltende ansätze in den relevanten
fragen der philosophie geht kaffee mit
behandelt wird dafür habe ich in hamburg
in der arbeitsstelle die sie erwähnt
haben mit der ausgabe der hamburger wie
der hamburger ausgabe der werke ernst
cassirer in 25 bänden zehn jahre lang
gearbeitet das erklärte ziel dieser
wiedergutmachungs aktion war schon von
anfang an dass er klassiker status der
cloud kassierer zukommt endlich
erkennbar werden sollte und das ist ja
wie wir alle wissen autoren herausgeber
verlage immer dann gewährleisten ist
eine gesamtausgabe
ich freue mich also wer sich hier heute
sehen kann wenn ich auch fürchte das ist
nochmal einen beitrag eine gewisse
enttäuschung geben
dazu sage ich gleich noch einige worte
in der einleitung des ersten der sprache
gewidmeten teile seiner philosophie der
symbolischen formen könig ernst cassirer
1923 eine grundlegung der
geisteswissenschaften an
bei einem autor werden sich im ersten
jahrzehnt dieses jahrhunderts als
berliner privatdozent seinen guten ruf
als der erkenntnis kassierer erworben
hatte den seitenwänden freier künstler
erkenntnisproblem in der philosophie und
wissenschaft der neueren zeit 1906 und
1907 liegt hier die erwartung womöglich
die befürchtung nahe dass er sich in
ähnlich abstrakt mit admeto
logischerweise wie in seiner ersten
systematischen schrift der abhandlung
kunstbegriff und funktions begriff
verleiten oder 10 mit der er einen
beitrag zur grundlegung der
mathematischen naturwissenschaften
vorgelegt hatte nunmehr auch den
geisteswissenschaften widmen wolle
doch man merkt schnell die
programmatische absichtserklärung ist
nicht so gemeint dass im folgenden das
mythologische wissen shop theoretische
interesse thematisch dominieren wollen
sollte offenbar lediglich in aussicht
gestellt werden dass dieser aspekt immer
auch im blick sei und tatsächlich ist es
zu den mitdenkenden leser evident dass
auf der philosophie der kultur die hier
entwickelt wird die grundlegung der
geisteswissenschaften so zwangsläufig
wie zwanglos hervor
ein typischer fall von kollateral meppen
wert ist auf der grundlegung ebene
dieser theorie dass kassierer den
begriff des geistes keineswegs bloß
konventionell übernimmt so wie man etwa
annehmen könnte dass er im gebrauch des
wissenschaft pragmatisch eingespielten
terminus geisteswissenschaften los in
kauf genommen würde
in seiner grundlegung der kultur in
einer philosophie der symbolischen
formen darf man viele einer
aktualisierende um nicht zu sagen eine
revitalisierende expedition dessen sehen
was der geist sei auf dem sich die
geisteswissenschaften beziehen
insofern kann hier und das ist die
enttäuschung die sich spontan bereiten
und keine rede sein von einer theorie
die bei der krise des geistes einsätze
oder von der krise des geistes zeugnis
ablegte der bezug auf den guide ist bei
charaktere und betont mit dem radfahrer
zu sagen dass ich in solchen fällen
aufdrängt so ab normativ und entfaltet
denkbar
von daher um das vorwegzunehmen hier nur
die alternative zwischen zwei
möglichkeiten entweder die veranstalter
sind zutiefst enttäuscht darüber dass
nun auch in der heutigen sektion krisen
des geistes eine klassische position
gedeutet zur geltung gebracht wird oder
wie lenken schnell ein und machen
raus in dem segment wie ein thema das
gestern abend in anschlag gebracht wurde
also gemäß der unterscheidung zwischen
den aktuellen oder ehemaligen münz
nahmen die sämtlich über klassische
position des geistes und den auswärtigen
die über position der krisen auf die
breites geißel vortragen mich zu einer
gestandenen münchnerin erklären mir das
sehr recht sein
kassierer selbst also um zur sache zu
kommen
beim symbolischen als dmax und vorfeld
der konstitution von bedeutung
er begreift das symbol als das element
der kultur und er betont an den
vielfältigen modi der symbolisierung die
in ihrer vernetzung der systemen der
kultur bilden den charakter der
hervorbringung von bedeutung durch die
verknüpfung geistiger gehalten mit
sinnlichen trägern als die momente des
kultur prozesse werden wir symbolen
bedeutung und geist in ihrem generischen
wirkungszusammenhang begriffen und in
ihrer funktion den menschlichen
orientierungs und handlungsraum zu
schaffen
und genau darin ist das symbolische in
allen seinen in laborierten ausprägungen
als die instanz bestimmt auf die sich
die geisteswissenschaften zu beziehen
haben schon herr logos clasicos zur
bestimmung des schlüsselbegriff dieses
ansatzes lässt erkennen wie hier alles
aus den geist hervorgeht das betrifft
die vereins auf dem handy unter einer
symbolischen form soll jede energie des
geistes verstanden werden durch welche
ein geistiger bedeutungsgehalt an ein
konkretes sinnliche zeichen geknüpft und
diesem zeichen innerlich zugeeignet wird
so heißt es 1923
den begriff der energie in dieser
definition der symbolischen formen
übernimmt kassierer der konstruktive
anklänge an physikalische theorien steht
bewegen in kauf nahmen
gleichwohl aus humboldts bestimmung der
sprache als energie die wir gestern
schon im referat von herrn neujahr
gestreift haben
die sprache sei als tätigkeit und arbeit
des geistes zu begreifen dass ihre nimmt
dies als exemplarisch und betont diese
tätigkeit und arbeitet geistes für alle
formen der kultur
was aber versteht er in diese richtung
von der energie des geistes unter geist
die frage stellt sich umso dringlicher
als sich in der zitierten stelle nicht
etwa um ein einmaliges singulär
exponierte vorkommendes geist begriffes
handelt kassierer spricht von den
symbolischen formen von geistigen formen
oder geistigen grundfunktionen es bringt
von der form des geistes wie das leben
als bewusstes und gestaltetes leben
annimmt jede kulturelle gestaltung warum
für ihn auf einer zitat ursprünglichen
tat des geistes zitat ende
in hinblick auf solche stellen
überrascht es nicht dass er in seiner
material reichen historischen und
systematischen darstellung der
symbolischen formen ausdrücklich auf
eine philosophische systematik des
geistes aus ist im begriff der
symbolischen formen sind nun die fähren
der kultur gemeint das was georg simmel
deren verschiedene sachen reihen
bezeichnet was andere autoren während
bereiche oder heute auch gerne
subsysteme nennen sprache mythos
religionen kunst wissenschaft technik
verstanden als die exemplarischen und
gleichsam sich institutionalisieren den
body menschlicher symbol
die struktur der symbolisierung die
vermittlung von gail und sinnlichem
trägt sich in den unterschiedlichsten
materialien oder medien ein ausdruck der
kassierer hier explizit und stahl
verwendet aus poliertem laut in bildern
in materiellen dingen ritualen
zeremonien und techniken überhaupt in
handlungen aller art in institutionen
welt in formeln kurz das wird wohl erste
kassierer ausdruck einer geistigen durch
sämtliche zeichen und bilder in seiner
weiteren bedeutung ziffer 2 auf dem
händler auf in den genannten steht
konkreten funktionen der energie des
geistes konstituiert sich im permanenten
spannungsverhältnis von kassierer sachen
innovation und tradition die dauerhafte
welt menschlicher wirklichkeit
es klingelt an schon in den ohren wenn
man das hört es ist nur allzu deutlich
dass kassiererin den geist in den
symbolischen formen als objektiviert und
gleichsam institutionalisiert nach der
art von hingis objektiven guides
vorstellt allerdings mit der extension
ahlen modifikation dass er auf religion
und kunden
die egl als absoluten geist begreift
diesen fairen der kultur und damit dem
was er als objektiven geist fassen welt
zuordnet es geht in diesem geist begriff
um die produktive spontaneität die sich
in den gesellschaftlichen formen des
menschlichen lebens objektiviert geist
ist kassierer ist für kassierer einzig
fassbar
als der geist der kultur
auf jeweils philosophie des geistes
spielt er offenkundig an wo er das ganze
gebiet der kultur skizziert und sagt die
sprache der mythos die theoretische
erkenntnis wie alle werden ihr als grund
gestalten des objektive geistes genommen
so weit wie offenkundige beziehung zu
hegel
ich will in der folgenden darstellung
einen eindruck davon vermitteln dass
dieser befund nur die halbe wahrheit
wäre denn offensichtlich sind in den
genannten formulierungen immer auch
exekutive variationen auf dem kantischen
begriff der spontaneität 1
selbsttätigkeit zu sehen und eben doch
offensichtlich ist es die schon bekannt
angelegte politische praktiziert dieser
spontanität die affäre systematisch aus
artikuliert und prägnant zu machen sucht
schon in rousses bestimmung der sprache
als energija war die kantige spontanität
konzeption eingegangen so dass man
gerade zu sagen kann wo kassierer kultur
philosophisch die formel von den
energien des geistes prägt das schwingt
immer auch der kantischen begriff des
vermögens mit und wo er diese formel in
der regel von allergien des bilden
variiert spitzt sich zu wo es ihm im
begriff des geistes geht
klarheit bringt hier im vierten band des
werkes das erkenntnisproblem in der
philosophie und wissenschaft der neueren
zeit erst posthum veröffentlicht 1957
das komplette über die wissenschaft
theorie der modernen biologie die laut
cafés einsicht mit kant beginnt hier
bezieht klassieren sich auf die stelle
in der kritik der urteilskraft in der
theorie delhi die der exekution seiner
reduktion der ästhetischen urteile die
soll die uns von gestern beschäftigt hat
die stelle an der kant geist in
ästhetische bedeutung als das belebende
prinzip im gemüt bestimmt dass wir
lebende prinzip in gemüte zitiert die
stelle falsch und zwar so dass lehrer
von der art wie die älteren unter uns
dennoch hatten hier von einem guten
fehler gesprochen hätten und viele
andere von einer ausgesprochen
glücklichen freudsche fehlleistung
er formuliert sind vier auf dem hemd
kant hat erklärt dass leighs in
ästhetischer bedeutung dass bildende
prinzip im gemüse sei dann sind sie
stellen an denen man am liebsten eine
flasche champagner erst aufmachen möchte
man überlege kommen weil man hier alles
was man braucht
er zieht nämlich damit kann bestimmung
des geistes in eigenwillige adaption an
sein eigenes systematisches interesse
ihm ging es um das bildende prinzip dass
er mit dem ausdruck geil bezeichnen will
es lohnt sich an dieser stelle kurz zu
rekapitulieren was kann mit diesem
begriff des geistes eigentlich im sinn
hat er spricht hier explizit soweit
zitiert kassiere ja richtig von geist in
ästhetischer bedeutung ästhetische
bedeutung hat der begriff hier insofern
als er zur charakterisierung der
spezifischen leistungen des produktiven
künstlers erforderlich ist also dessen
der bei seinem publikum das freie spiel
der erkenntnis kräfte auszulösen vermag
die produktive leistungspunkte des
bildenden künstlers oder auch das sprach
bildenden künstlers welche kant als die
darstellung ästhetischer ideen
bezeichnet unter einer ästhetischen idee
versteht er die wenige vorstellungskraft
der ein vorstellung der einbildungskraft
die viel zu denken solle anlass ohne
dass ihr doch irgend ein bestimmter
bedanken
das ist begriff adäquat sein kann
die folglich keine sprache völlig
erreicht und verständlich machen kann
und das vermögen zur darstellung
ästhetischer ideen ist es was den
künstler auszeichnet entscheidend ist
dabei dass kant das kunstwerk prima
fahrt hier also eine hervorbringung
durch freiheit begreift zum zeitpunkt
der kritik der urteilskraft ist der
kritische freiheitsbegriff bereits
entfaltet er umfasst transzendentale
freiheit als spontanität und als
autonomie exemplifiziert als
willensfreiheit die sich in der
moralische qualifizierten
selbstbestimmung des handelns
artikuliert dem blatt assoziiert der
leser an der stelle an der das kunstwerk
eine hervorbringung durch freiheit
genannt wird richtig kunstwerken
verdammten sich wehren sich dem vermögen
im subjekt von dem jede selbstbestimmung
im erkennen und denken wie im handeln
ausgeht
im künstlerischen subjekt wird die
freiheit dieses vermögen zur bestimmung
und welt bestimmungen in besonderer
weise prägnant
sie nimmt mit einer besonderen
organisatorischen vorfahren jene luxury
ihren die intensität an bekannt als
geist bezeichnet die fünf im handout ich
stelle möchte ich ihnen in dem
zusammenhang nicht vorenthalten
man sagt von gewissen produkten von
welchen man erwartet dass sie sich zum
teil wenigstens als schöne kunst zeigen
sollten
sie sind ohne geist ob man an ihnen was
den geschmack betrifft nichts zu tage
und findet ein gedicht kann recht nett
und entität elegant sein aber es ist
obergeil eine geschichte ist genau und
ordentlich aber ohne geist eine
feierliche rede gründlich und zugleich
ziemlich aber ohne geist manche
konversation ist mich ohne unterhaltung
aber doch ohne geist selbst von einem
frauenzimmer sagt man wohl
sie ist hübsch gespräche und artig aber
ohne auf die selbst gestellte frage was
ist denn das was man hier unter geist
versteht gibt kann sich die antwort
geist in ästhetischer bedeutung heißt
das belebende prinzipien gemüte
schon in dieser bestimmung wird
erkennbar dass der begriff des geistes
die planer haben soll
zugleich mit dem charakter eines
prinzips also eines ursprungs an diesem
dieckow extension von lebendigkeit und
produktivität zu betonen
im begriff der darstellung also bei
darstellung ästhetischer ideen ist schon
bei kant diese produktivität impliziert
und auf dem ersten blick den genialen
künstler vorbehalten
doch man muss nur sehen dass das genie
bei kant nicht als das ganz anderes
sondern als das exemplarische subjekt
begrüßen ist um nachvollziehen zu können
wieso der kantige geist begriff als das
angeblich will diese prinzipien gemüte
in der optik kassierers tauglich sein
kann
das poetische prinzip der kultur als das
der gestaltung aller lebensbereiche
durch alle abzugeben
ganz ihre freundliche übernahme des
kandischen begriffs eines geistes der
gemäss seinem expedia tiven kontext der
des künstlers ist könnte somit wenn die
überhaupt noch nötig sein sollte
die letzte probe auf den charakter je
nach dem logischen meter fiel weg sein
welche die philosophie der symbolischen
formen tatsächlich zu lesen ist
denn tiere darin dabei in der betonung
des bildenden prinzip dessen von kant
betonte lebendigkeit nicht über geht
sondern gerade bewahrt dass er an diesem
begriff des geistes die implikation der
lebendigkeit spontan auf dem
menschlichen bewusstsein entspringende
akte und prozesse besonders schätzt
leidet keinen zweifel es ist
insbesondere 1930 der aufsatz über geist
und leben in der philosophie der
gegenwart
es ist mit anderen worten die
auseinandersetzung mit dem verhältnis
von geist und leben in der anthropologie
nach china
die darüber den entscheidenden
aufschluss gibt schüler vorstellung von
einem sprung auf der kontinuität des
biologischen lebens in die ihm gänzlich
unverbundene sphäre des geistes die den
menschen zum menschen macht verhilft
passiert zur schärfung der einrichtung
muss als etwas selber lebendiges und
leben als ursprung bezweifelt insofern
selber als etwas geistiges gefragt
werden er nimmt sie überhaupt zum anlass
weiterführender grund bestimmungen
seiner eigenen philosophie der kultur
als einer phänomenologie des geistes
geist ist dass bildende prinzip im
bemühte das heißt in nicht in kategorien
nicht des 18ten jahrhundert
transformiert geist ist dass bildende
prinzip in jenem subjekt in der kultur
prozent seinen ursprung hat und das
heißt im prinzip in jedem subjekt und
eine energie das gleiche passiere
erläuterungen der symbolischen form wäre
dann die im sinne eines typus bestimmte
tätigkeit in der dieses bildende prinzip
licht aus legt ein fragment über geist
und leben und der zeit nach dem dritten
teil der philosophie der symbolischen
formen also ende der 20er anfang der
dreißiger jahre im kontext aus dem auch
die auseinandersetzung mit matschiner
stammt und in dem kassierer inmitten
ausgiebiger auseinandersetzungen mit
alex song ludwig klare und georg wimmel
auch den eigenen begriff und die eigene
theorie markiert gibt den befund
deutlichere konturen der geist von
dessen gehalt konkreten gebilden seine
philosophie der symbolischen formen
handelt ist demnach wille zur gestaltung
seiner absicht die formung der welt zwei
mögliche missverständnisse sind in
dieser konzeption des reise von
vornherein ausgeschlossen
das missverständnis bekannten tandem und
das missverständnis der substantially
sierung das missverständnis der
transzendenz dass der geistig in einer
irgendein abgehobenen fähre aufhielten
ja dass er sich überhaupt unabhängig
isoliert vom physischen substrates
sämtlichen ausmachen und bestimmen ließe
im grunde ist es der gedanke den kann
schon in seiner widerlegung des
idealismus in der zweiten auflage der
kritik der reinen vernunft deutlich zu
machen versucht dass es eine
widersinnige konzeption wäre
intelligente funktionen so zu denken als
liefen sie sich überhaupt als leistungen
fassen ohne sie als solche immer schon
auf andere ihrer welt bezogen zu haben
der auch in kassierers konzeption des
symbolischen als der funktional
verknüpfung von geistigen
bedeutungsgehalt und konkreten
sinnlichem zeichen wirksam ist
so kommt auch kassierer weit entfernt
von dem naiven unterstellungen mit denen
es der grip und theorie des geistes in
unserem heutigen zeit geistigen umfeld
notorisch zu tun bekommen nicht in
versuchung den geist so zu denken als
schwebte er über den war stand er fast
unter diesem begriff in einer anhand
geschulten begrifflichkeit das
produktive und dabei immer auf der
objektivierung in einem materiellen
medium ausgerichtete prinzip des welt
bildenden menschlichen bewusstseins das
vermögen der formung von von zu fahren
das reicht schon wenn man das dann das
missverständnis der super vitalisierung
bestünde darin dass geist überhaupt
anders als in seinem prozess wahlen wird
anders denn als tätigkeit begreifbar
wäre in geltung bleibt auch in diesem
begriff kassierer früher einsicht in den
primat der funktions begriffe die tiere
auch diese stelle finden sie jetzt
müsste zittern
sechs sein auf dem handy der begriffen
geist des korrekt aber wir dürfen ihn
nicht als name einer substanz gebrauchen
für einen rekord im dfb
die konzert tour wir sollten ihn in
einem funktionellen simmel gebrauchen
als einen umfassenden rahmen für alle
jene funktionen wie die welt der
menschlichen kultur konstituieren und
aufbauen
wer kalt den kassierer als dass bildende
prinzip begreift realisiert sich als
lebendiges wirken ihn lauter produktiven
funktionen und ist darin bezogen auf
seine auf seine das heißt sie ihn core
relativ gegenübersteht materie
er zeigt sich nicht anders als in stets
neu und auf neue zu leistenden
funktionen der verkörperung von
bedeutung
wir hätten unseren absprechen sollen
über unsere vorträge aber ich möchte es
hat nichts genutzt die hätte dieser
jetzt trotzdem sagen müssen die geistige
energie kann demgemäß nicht anders
gedacht werden als so lassen sich in
etwas betätigt das als ihr medium
fungiert die verkauf hat sich sagt
kassierer in der gestaltung kultureller
werke wenn er formuliert auch diese
stelle finden sie auf dem handy
der gehalt leistungs erschließt sich nur
in seiner äußerung die ideale form wird
erkannten nur an und in dem inbegriff
der sinnlichen zeichen deren sich zum
ausdruck bedient dann sind es in der in
westend auf der äußerung als tätiger
funktion und ihrem korrelat im
sinnlichen zeichen als dem medium der
äußerung uno akten beide
missverständnisse das missverständnis
der transzendent und das missverständnis
der substantia regierung die hier
ausgeschlossen werden
mit dem stichwort der verkörperung von
kassierer häufig und einschlägig
verwendet wo es um den charakter der
symbolischen formen geht ist deutlicher
noch als in der sachlich äquivalenten
formulierung von der verknüpfung von
geistigem bedeutungsgehalt und konkrete
sinnlichem zeichen die symptomatische
absicht in metaphysische perfekte liebe
artikuliert die kassierer mit seinem
symbol theoretischen ansatz verbindet in
der unhintergehbare des symbolischen für
die konstitution menschlicher wirksam
wirklichkeit erweist sich so denkt
kassierer der platonische die der
katholische dualismus als über unten
besondere prägnant verleiht kassierer
diesem in der philosophie der
symbolischen formen stets mit geführten
programm das wie gesagt exakt an der
konzeption des symbolischen als jener
verknüpfung hängt an einer stelle in
deren dritten teil wo er in provokativer
inversion die leib seele einheit zum
aussagekräftigen modell aller
symbolisierung erklärt auch diese stelle
haben liegen auf dem handy auf das
verhältnis von leib und seele stellt das
erste vorbild und musterbild für eine
rein symbolische relation da die sich
weder in eine ding beziehung noch in
eine kausale beziehung um denken lässt
hier gibt es ursprünglich weder ein
innen und außen noch ein vorher oder
nachher ein wirkendes oder bewirkte hier
waltet eine verknüpfung die nicht auf
getrennt und elementen ersten
zusammengefügt zu werden braucht sondern
primär ein sinnerfülltes ganze ist dass
sich selbst interpretiert nicht allein
der adva die aale ausdruck ursprünglich
indiziert an der rein symbolischen
relation dass sie unvergängliche
ganzheit stiftet eine system synthese
der gegenüber e
fläche teilung allenfalls die einer
nachträglichen analytischen
unterscheidung sein kann und es wird
wohl deutlich dass ich an der hier
provozierten auf die probe gestellten
und in der zurückweisung von lauter
diese motiven relationen forcierten
angemessenen verständnis der
symbolischen relation die sich wieder in
eine ding beziehung noch in eine kausale
beziehung umdenken lässt und auch weder
ein innen und außen noch ein vorher oder
nachher ein wirkendes oder bewirkte
gliedern lässt das gelingen der
angestrebten übersendung des dualismus
entscheidet genau das soll von dem was
er hier von der leib seele einheit
geltend gemacht sein
extrapoliert und was er hier von derlei
pläne einheit geltend macht extra
poliert werden leistet jedes symbol
wir haben kassierer also ernst zu nehmen
in seinem postulat wenn er sagt hier
waltet eine verknüpfung die nicht aus
getrennten elementen er zusammengefügt
zu werden braucht sondern die primär ein
sinnerfülltes ganze ist von postulat
spreche hier gleichwohl weil wir wissen
dass eine solche absicht im programm
leichter zu haben ist als in der
durchführung ob ihre durchführung
gelingt hängt mich allein an einsichten
und argumenten die belegen dass sie
erforderlich ist noch allein an
grundbegriffen die imstande sind die
programmatische absicht zu tragen
sondern immer auch an der konsequenz des
langen atems bei der expedition alle von
der theorie erfassten zusammenhänge
müssen sich so explizit ihren lassen
dass der gedanke der ursprünglichen
einheit und ganzheit erfüllt ist von
daher muss es und herrschen hier
schließe ich mich der
problematisierung des verkörperung des
begriffs an von daher muss es zu denken
geben dass im kontext der bereits
angeführten stelle über das vorbild und
musterbild der symbolischen relation
nicht nur von innen erfüllung
besinnlichen sondern auch explizit von
besonderen und von verkörperung die rede
ist spezifizierung und im exemplifiziert
eines allgemeinen gehalt das anschaulich
machen und lebendig machen von
abstrakten begriffen und gedanken im
sinnlichen medium im anschaulichen
material und in diesem sinne deren
konkretisierung das ist generell die
bedeutung dieser tiere im anschluss an
hebeln sie an güte dem verkörperung
begriff gibt man sieht leicht wie die
funktion des symbols eben diese
systematische intention aufnehmen und
erfüllen soll
man sieht aber auch welchen problemen
die verkörperung terminologie dabei
aufwirft um es ganz knapp auf den punkt
zu bringen substantive rungen mit dem
präfix indizieren stets eine
nachträglich kleid der operation und
ihre perfekt für den begriff der
verkörperung heißt dies ein vorgängig
nicht körperliches wird nachträglich mit
einem körper ausgestattet oder umgeben
die frage ist liegt in dieser
ausdrucksweise eine sprachliche
ungeschicklichkeit oder ist es ein
eingeständnis der grenze an welche die
intention der überwindung des dualismus
wenn doch stoßen muss vor diesem
hintergrund muss man auch noch einmal
auf die bestimmung der symbolischen form
zurückkommen unter einer symbolischen
form soll jede energie des geistes
verstanden werden durch welche ein
geistiger bedeutungsgehalt an ein
konkretes ähnliches zeichen geknüpft und
diesen zeichen innerlich zugeeignet wird
es konnte nicht verborgen bleiben dass
hier der eindruck begünstigt wird als
gebe es zeichen schon vor der
symbolischen formen diese bestünde dann
darin einen offenbar autonomen geistigen
bedeutungsgehalt an einen seinerseits
irgendwie in der welt schon fix und
fertig vorhandenes zeichen zu knüpfen
die frische kraft jener energie des
geistes als die kassierer die
symbolische form verstanden wissen
und das produkt dieser verknüpfung
zweier und theologisch selbständiger
entitäten wäre das symbol
hier muss man entschieden protestieren
wir wissen genug vom duktus dieser
theorie um sagen zu dürfen dass es so
nicht gemeint ist wir haben viel mehr
mit einer suboptimalen formulierung zu
tun
in der der autor ganz offenbar nicht auf
der höhe seiner eigenen konzeption
bleibt also offenkundig ist es dass ich
nach ihrer die sache viel mehr so denkt
das sinnliche sind in der verknüpfung
mit dem geistigen bedeutungsgehalt aller
erstes zeichen in dieser relation wird
nicht nur das sinnliche sondern auch der
geistige bedeutungsgehalt erst konkret
und das ganze ist das symbol nun
wiederholt sich dem problem dass auf
diese weise mit einem loyalen
hermeneutischen takte des wohlwollens zu
lösen sind im begriff der verkörperung
durch die implikationen der nachträglich
kite gegenüber einem früheren
beziehungsweise prioritären dabei ist
allemal zu konzedieren dass in der in
westend auf verkörperung dort schon viel
gewonnen sein kann wo es primär darum
geht überhaupt den verdacht gegen das
sinnliche auszuräumen und die
notwendigkeit seiner unverzichtbaren
beteiligung ein richtig zu machen
doch es dürfte kaum in frage stehen ob
die schon auf reicht für das was als
überwindung des do erlitten und in
aussicht gestellt war
gewiss ist der entgegennahme zum von
körper und seele von materie und geist
im konzept der verkörperung die spitze
genommen
doch mit der besagten implikationen der
nachträglich kite bleibt erkennbar der
primat des geistigen in geltung und das
ist es wohl auch was bei aller
anerkennung realistische ansprüche unter
idealismus zu verstehen ist jenem
idealismus den kassierer fühlen sich in
dem projekt die kritik der vernunft in
die kritik der kultur zu transformieren
experten in anspruch nimmt
wahrscheinlich ist systematisch
überhaupt nicht mehr zu haben
da alles andere auf eine spontanität der
materie hinausliefe und damit auf eine
verdoppelung des geist prinzip die noch
größeren explorations probleme ja nicht
einmal bloss zur ecke kation problemen
führte doch die stelle über das
verhältnis von leib und seele als erstes
vorbild und musterbild für eine rein
symbolische relation hatte mehr
versprochen so dass hier eine frage
offen bleibt
ich würde dies allerdings auch nicht als
eine krise sondern als eine komplikation
in der theorie des geistes begreifen
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit